[Music]
i want you guys to take a look at this
graphic right here
subway series yeah you like it is it a
new league
no it's a it's a new promotional like
series they're doing do sandwiches
it's nothing different than regular
subway but this graphic would you ever
get a tattooed on your body
your chest or back
no way oh wait is this what the like
what the campaign is to get this
tattered on you no unless i'm jared if
i'm jared i'll get attacked
he doesn't have room and he's been in
prison in a while i need the new
publicity yeah i need people to forget
about the child molester so they're
awarding someone who's willing to tattoo
this on their body
free subway for life for life that's not
a good price i barely even want one
subway yeah it's more like it's like a
sentence i bet there's a line of people
waiting to do that though and why i
believe this is because someone got mr
chao
um ken jong is that mr his character's
name
tattooed on his like body why i don't
know so i feel like if there's people
that do that there's definitely people
that will do it oh yeah because now
you're actually getting something in
exchange yo tell a homeless person about
this i was taking the chance yeah you
know what i'm saying let me get it right
here go ahead you know
you know me like they don't give up for
life and then you're gonna be screwed
that subway's gonna be like sorry we
don't serve homeless people
wow
my god but i have the [ __ ] tattoo my
guy like what that's a twilight zone
episode right there you know like hey
get get subway tattooed in your body get
free subway for life oh sorry we don't
we don't serve the homeless
and then the and then this one this
specific one why couldn't it be a dope
one i know you don't say it like
like in old english right it's like it
couldn't be something dope but now it's
like it's this limited series thing
that's probably not gonna exist later so
no i don't even know any tattoo artists
that use green and yellow ink yeah yeah
they're like oh we got that you gotta go
to subway tattoo artist it's weird
because it is like like if you've got a
pepsi one but you got like pepsi smash
which they don't even do anymore it's
like wait why do i have this
so they're not it's not that anyone can
do it there's like they're going to pick
from a bunch of like entries oh wow
yeah and then the least homeless person
gets it doesn't it
it's only one guy that gets it that's
[ __ ] up
they're probably gonna do all kinds of i
don't know metrics and figure out who
could get it that's not going to eat the
sandwiches oh yeah i bet you yeah cause
they're what it is they're gonna give
you a card every year like it'll expire
every year they'll give you a new card
that uh you can get a certain amount for
that year i need to talk to their
marketing department because i'm just
like dude if you guys just fixed your
sandwiches you wouldn't have to do
stupid gimmicky [ __ ] like this and if it
tasted like quiznos i would go there way
more yeah yeah is this really gonna move
subway sales yeah
just make it taste better i know i know
yeah but nope they're doing this maybe
this is their uh a big step in the
direction of repairing their reputation
another sham about subway is it like
that never looks
i never taste what it looks like too and
they go fresh baked bread and the bread
is like freshly stale
like it comes out [ __ ] up yeah i have
a question i have a question
let's say like you know those of you
that aren't married or with other
significant others but like you got
single and you you're with a girl and
you're having you know coitus
and you do it in the doggy fashion not
to say it's so sexy your girl your girl
has the subway series tatted on her
lower back
what are
did you really just sign up for that
contest to get a free you know the free
sandwiches yeah like i don't know i
think i'd be so much in my head i'd be
like i'm obsessed with six inches
yes well after this six inch we're gonna
go get a six inch i don't know if they
want to see a real six yeah
it's more like four and a half but
[Laughter]
so if you get a smaller tattoo by the
way you can so the one that you have to
get is 12 by 12 inches
holy [ __ ] it's freaking huge but if you
get a three by three i think there's
like uh three people who
um or eight people who are eligible
they'll get a three by three tattoo and
they get free subway for a month
what yeah this is dude that's not even
close this is terrible
it's actually good at subway though
the cookies the spicy the cookies
cookies are fine also i'm like is it
because the sandwich tastes so much like
ass that it made the cookie taste nah
the cookie is good bro yeah cause the
cookies
it's like a little bit chewy in the
middle yeah it's a little crunchy
macadamia nut you know what i mean yeah
i like the spicy bmt if i have to go to
subway that's what i get spicy teeth
fire yeah bmt oh obviously that just
sounds like a porn category
spicy
you guys ever wonder like this is a
funny thing to think but like you ever
wonder these things that award
free something for life to people that
they just wait a while
once the hype dies down
find the guy just
[Laughter]
for sure whoever wins i wouldn't be
surprised like a year and a half later
they turn up dead under mysterious
circumstances you know the subway mafia
is like dude but the guy that gets the
tattoo after a month of getting free
subway he's not going to go back for a
while and i like how our all of our
scenarios has been a guy getting this
because we know a woman would just laugh
dude
i've never seen a girl in subway ever
yes trevor we actually have a couple of
members at barbara brigade that are
about to get a percent free membership
for life why so our program it's 100
bucks a month but every year uh for
loyalty we take ten percent off
so if it's a hundred bucks a hundred
bucks the next year it's ninety dollars
next year it's eighty right that's ex
that's
yeah so we have guys uh that are about
so it's 2002 yeah we have guys at the
nine-year mark
and then so they're paying 10 bucks a
month now they're about to get it 100
for free wow
and they're probably already jacked if i
if i die i don't know what happens to
or if the gym doesn't exist anymore i
don't know what happens in lifetime
membership
[Laughter]
it's not for your lifetime it's for
barbells
right when you give it to them you
should be like oh just to let you guys
know we're closing next month just just
like hey
thanks for the 90 years are there any
are there any like disloyalty penalties
where it goes up yeah oh you got to pay
110 now yeah i saw you at 24 hours yeah
yeah i saw you over there
[Laughter]
let's start that that's what subway
needs overhead's gonna be rough because
you've got so many private investigators
to pay but yeah
there was this it's not a lifetime free
thing but the um american airlines was
giving away this thing where it's like
if you pay like a hundred grand or
something
you get lifetime
free flights what yeah and they lost so
much money
are there people still doing it no the
guy that did it so he he got it and then
you with the benefit of that is also you
can give miles away
so he got his family all miles and stuff
but i don't think american airlines
whoever came up with this promotion
didn't think about beyond like a year
and so this guy was flying everywhere
with his family and everything they were
losing
like i think at that point like hundreds
of thousands of dollars if not millions
of dollars because he was flying
everywhere because he was usurped it's a
first-class ticket everywhere anywhere
first class how much do you have to pay
to buy into that is i think it was like
100 yeah it was like
and then at the time people didn't have
that money to like just use on this yeah
so he he saw the benefit of it so it's
like he called their bluff kind of thing
pretty much yeah and then they cancelled
it on him and he sued he sued and then
he lost he appealed the people he lost
and like
his daughter was like he's better now
but for a long time he was really
distraught about the whole thing because
basically they just pulled the rug from
under like hey no we didn't that's very
on brand with american airlines
they cancel
every
flight i've ever been with i don't know
what it is but do you hear hearing that
i'm like that makes sense that's a move
that they do they'll just cancel it
right out of nowhere we've also lost my
luggage and said it was my fault
everyone really of course it's your
fault you're gonna fall because you for
trusting them i guess
you shouldn't have trusted this [ __ ]
[ __ ] what's wrong with you idiot
we're trusting though you're loyal it's
like one of my last choices i fly spirit
before i fly american airlines oh that's
really bad yeah
kind of nice
i like that you came in here for 18
bucks
18
you can't be mad you can't be mad dude
that's why i expect the service to me
it's like getting on the plane like like
a subway train
not bad for 18 bucks
that's like eating a subway that's like
eating a subway cold cut and getting mad
because it tastes like [ __ ] i'm just
like i know what i bought yeah okay yeah
but american airlines i'm like you're
trying to compete with delta yeah you
got a long way to go and i got to pay
all the delta prices for american
airlines yeah true it's like come on man
i'd rather go delta get yelled at by old
lady and [ __ ] you know did you guys see
that um there was like a similar thing
when pepsi did a sweepstakes about
points back in i think like the 90s they
had this thing where uh certain points
like by buying pepsi products you can
redeem them and you'll get like a pepsi
jacket or a pepsi shirt yeah and then in
the commercial just as a joke the punch
line at the end of the commercial they
bring in this harrier jet that lands and
they're like oh for 50 million billion
points you get the harrier jet it was
like supposed to be funny right
one guy goes okay we're going to
he found out this loophole that uh
within the pepsi sweepstakes if you
didn't buy enough products to get those
points you could buy the points
for a very very low amount he did the
math and figured out that harrier jet
which cost like how what is like a half
a billion bucks or something like i
don't know what it is he found out that
it would be cheaper to just buy all the
points that they said the harrier jet
cost in the commercial
and then turn that in
and he did that and pepsi was like no
it's just a joke and then he tried to
sue for it
ended up he ended up losing but because
of that lawsuit now every commercial
when they ironically or sarcastically
advertise they're not allowed to do that
wow
so that's that's the birth of that
because of this hairier jet see suing
always ruins fun [ __ ] yeah
always the literalist with all the money
i know
you guys uh
ever used to smoke cigarettes and
collect the marble miles
wow you know i remember you get like
jackets and [ __ ] it was so sick it was
like so you know like supreme puts like
their brand on everything yeah so you
could get like marble jackets [ __ ]
like golf clubs that was really cool
back everything yeah and i wanted the
jacket so bad so i collected a [ __ ] ton
right and then
they just discontinued doing that at
that time that is funny it's like i got
these golf clubs through lung cancer
i worked hard for these
smoking all the way to it the pool table
was a big thing
worth it
dude in college did you guys have
cigarette companies like
have signed up sheets
at the college so our school like
marlborough would come and they would
like because they want people to smoke
because you're 18 now you could buy
cigarettes
so i don't i've never smoked in my life
but i signed up for the list but this
particular list i don't know what it was
they would send me gifts
like every few months to smoke
cigarettes yeah like so like they would
send me coupons for cigarettes so i'll
give them to my friends because they'd
be like buy one get one free which for
cigarette people are like it's a crazy
coupon and then so they would say
initially they would send me like the
marlboro cookbook like summer cookbook
but then and then i would get like some
random like horseshoe but then i'd get
like shot glasses i get like all these
just throwing all the
fighter on the office this is crazy
that's basically what it was it was so
bizarre
[Music]
[Music]